what you want to memorize X minus H the
quantity squared plus y minus K the
quantity squared equals R squared so
just a quick review H comma K those are
the coordinates of the center of the
circle right so here's your circle there
is the center and then R that's the
distance from the center of the circle
to any point on the circle so that's
your radius but notice it's the radius
squared in this standard form of the
equation of a circle so let's do two
examples and I'll show you how this
works so example number one we have the
centers at negative 2 0 and the radius
is 16 so what we want to do is we want
to put this is our H and this is our
case we want to put those values in here
so we have X minus negative 2 squared
plus y minus 0 squared equals the radius
squared so 16 squared so when you
subtract a negative it's like adding the
opposite so that's really like X plus 2
squared and Y minus 0 is really just
like Y so I'm just going to write Y
squared and then 16 squared is equal to
256 now a lot of